before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
drink up me hotties Yoho
laughs
we are almost done with my re-watch of
the 13th doctor's era which will
actually have me properly caught up I
will not even consider
doing a re-watch of anything that airs
from uh the time point at which I end up
finishing this next week
um until after at the very least the end
of Judy God was Era how many ever many
seasons that goes like I don't want to
be doing like but for me part of the
reason to revisit and do the take two
reviews is you're looking at it with the
perspective of and we and this error is
wrapped up so let's reassess it knowing
everything that goes on
um so that's my current stance I'm sure
some people will like within a year be
nudging me to see if I'll do a take two
on the David tennis specials that are
coming out my intention right now is no
but anyways that's talking about the
future let's talk about the present or
the past because this is an episode from
like over a year ago at whatever legend
of the sea Devils now
this is a pretty maligned episode
uh is the general impression that I have
gotten and I kind of get why
but I also don't hate it this is one of
those things where like I'm Not Really
Gonna defend it
but
I don't have that much investment in
heaping hate onto it like there's a
couple things I'm going to bring out
point out uh and highlight but by and
large
I
the thing is
I think there's one major thing
hampering anybody's potential enjoyment
of this especially at the time that it
aired which is that there's no reason
for this to be special
it's not in any way picking up on any of
the stuff that happened at the end of
Series 13 or the end of series 12 for
that matter it's not really running a
through line from the previous episode
it's not even really loading the bases
for uh Power of the doctor coming up
it's just
it's just a very standard episode
but it's a standard episode masquerading
as a special despite the fact that it
has no additional length no additional
scope doesn't tie into anything else so
even though it is technically special I
just don't think of it like one I just I
think of this as a standard episode
because that's what it is this is
incredibly standard and I'll also admit
I am inclined to be slightly gentler
slightly gentler on this than I might
otherwise be for the same reason I was
slightly gentler on the black spot
I like Pirates I like the feel the
adventure the aesthetic I like pirate
stories I just do so anything that's
kind of going in for that you get a bit
of benefit of the doubt for me that
other people might not give it
and the thing is this is one of those
episodes uh or reviews rather of an
episode that could end up being really
short
because it basically amounts to
I I still kind of have fun with it but
it's not that great and honestly I could
probably leave it there that's basically
how everything's gonna be summed up in
the end I'll point out some specifics up
the thing is as I go I'm gonna sound
more negative on it than I intend to
partially because the stuff that is kind
of nice is not that great and the stuff
that is easier to talk about are some of
the problems so I'll end up dwelling
much more on the stuff that doesn't work
but
I don't hate this I don't love it I
don't hate this it's just an episode
it's just a bog standard episode and I
really think if it wasn't masquerading
as a special I think people would have
been kinder to it
but
like I said Pirates also see Devils who
I'm
I also kind of like I'm not sure they've
ever had a really great story their
first story is their best one with
um John Perth weight
but having Revisited that a little while
back
um on the secondary Channel break room
of Geeks I I found that that does not
hold up quite as well as my memory had
it it's a little bloated
um but it's still decent I still kind of
like them I like that this design is not
a rework this is basically the same
design the only real difference that
they do is they have
just a little motion tweening on the
face not even like to simulate mouth
movement because he's got like the
glowing
thing to indicate like that that's
translating for him or something but
like sort of implying pulsing of within
the mouth or in the throat and the
effect doesn't look great I mean that
like that's another thing this episode
doesn't look especially good I think a
lot of it was the hampering of still
shooting under covid because especially
like some of the action scenes there's a
lot of really awkward close-ups and
there's a distinct lack of any long
shots where there are multiple
characters in a frame which I suspect
was just a side effect of covid and
having to shoot under lockdown which I'm
pretty sure this had to do so and I mean
if it didn't if I've got my timing wrong
on that which I don't think I do but if
I do well
then they just didn't do a good job
but
you know there is some recurrence of
some things I've complained about
chimney before we have as soon as the uh
our main villain uh version of a sea
devil gets free from that statue he uh
just goes about massacring this Village
when there's no need for him to do that
like there's a need for him to kill uh
the guy's father and motivate that guy's
story fine
um but like he wipes out a huge section
of the village and there's like bodies
lying around I'm like why just have them
run like there's no need for again sort
of the the needless level of of violence
although it doesn't suffer from part of
what has really ticked me off about
chipmunk doing that before which is that
uh let's take a second to characterize
these people just enough where it feels
like knife twisting he didn't do that
here it is just fodder this is cannon
fodder but it is pointless cannon fodder
so there's that we have Madame Ching uh
well that's sort of the main thing she's
referred to here the historical figure
zengi Sao which I may have butchered and
I apologize now she's a very cool person
and I'm not sure this is a particularly
great representation of her now I don't
necessarily mean like betraying her you
know personality I don't know enough
about her to make a call on that and
that's not really my place but what I
will say is like from what I know of her
it's weird to stick her in for a sort of
swashbuckling direct action Captain kind
of pirate role
he was a fleet commander
she wasn't getting in there with a sword
swinging it to takeover ship herself she
commanded a fleet
as you pretty much started at that level
because she inherited that Fleet from
her husband who had been uh you know
kind of a pirate lord she inherited from
him when he died so she was a she was
top of the pyramid kind of leader she
was commanding the troops she was
sending fleets out to do stuff she
wasn't piloting ships herself at least
not so far as I am aware so it is a
little bit odd that they went with her
as opposed to like literally any other
pirate even any other female pirate who
might have fit that better in terms of
what have they actually historically did
and again I don't want to necessarily
say that that's
um like of a smirching or a dishonoring
of the historical figure it just it just
struck me as a little bit odd what I do
think might count as a little bit of a
smirching of the historical figure is
there's this big emphasis on this other
guy
um G hun from several hundred years
previous who I don't think was real like
I couldn't find evidence of this guy
like any search I tried to do just
brought me right back to this episode so
if he's a real historical figure who's
just so there's so much less known about
him that the Doctor Who version has
supplanted whatever real information is
out there in like a Google search or
what have you then if that's the case I
apologize but I don't think it is and
not only does it feel like he gets more
highlights he gets like these weird
heavy praising things like
that kind of stuff usually gets reserved
for the actual historical figures that
that that felt a little a little off and
a little weird I still like her being
there because I think the actress that
they got has a good sense of presence
and a good Charisma and again I do still
like a pirate archetype character even
if
um Madame Ching is maybe not the best
fit for the kind of pirate archetype
they're going for but
whatever this this is my generalized
knowledge maybe they did deep research
and there's a lot more precedent for the
way they chose to do it I honestly don't
know but this is just my understanding
as a layperson who is not a historian
just somebody who likes Pirates we have
I I want to say a continuation of the
Yasmin doctor thing but
barely there's the scene at the bottom
of the ocean where you know the doctor
just kind of let slip casually
and then you know Yaz gets all weird and
the doctor gets a little weird so like
this is kind of the confirmation that
the doctor is not blind to the
connection that exists between them
she's just not dealing with it and I
will say that later when they have their
one-on-one conversation about it it
works better than my memory it basically
amounts to like a very tried and true
explanation for any kind of immortal
loner which is that if I do fix myself
to somebody
I know sooner or later
it'll hurt
normally I'd kind of call like like
that's such a tropey basic answer for
this except
I actually kind of buy it from her
because she's been unusually distant
from her companions for her entire run
I I actually personally kind of feel
it's a little bit at least from me a bit
of a criticism of the era that she
doesn't build a deeper connection really
with any of them she seems reserved in
that way
and when I say criticism for me I don't
mean it's necessarily bad it's just
something I don't like because I like I
really hone in on the doctor companion
Dynamic and when it's not
um when it's not as firm or as deep it
it feels like the the show's missing
something but
knowing that knowing she hasn't had that
real deep connection with any of them
this answer comes off less like the kind
of cop-out it might have otherwise more
like an explanation for retroactively
explaining why
she hasn't let any of them in yes or
anyone else and her admitting to that
now is about as close as she's gonna
come to letting Yaz in and in a way it
kind of reminds me of that moment that
so many other people hate but I think is
good with with um the episode can you
hear me where she's with graham where
she says I should say a reassuring thing
now shouldn't I
I'm still not sexually awkward so I'm
just gonna certainly walk towards the
console in a minute
I'll think of something that I should
have said
where I've always read that scene as her
letting him in
on why she's about to do the somewhat
distanced somewhat awkward not ideal
thing that she's about to do she can't
stop herself from doing the thing but
she can let him in on what it is she's
about to do and like to basically be
aware that I know this is not the ideal
response but this is still what I'm
gonna do in this moment with Yaz Rings a
little bit like that this sort of
I can't give you what you want
what I can do is explain to you why and
that seems about the best that this
particular doctor is able to do as far
as opening up and so that scene I
actually think is decent the one before
that under the sea is
I don't know it's a little flat and also
it's weird because the again I have to
chalk this up to trying to shoot under
coveted restrictions and just the way it
was staged and they couldn't reshoot
stuff but like the doctor is looking
down and the whole seabed is like
cracking and falling away and like it's
loud and yes it's not indicated that Yaz
is like back inside the target she's
looking out and she's not even looking
up she's just like looking out and for
some reason she doesn't notice this like
there's a lot of weird wonkiness like
that throughout the thing but again I
chalk most of that up to covet shooting
oh and like there was one other part
from um from the doctor and Yaz that I
quite like where she where the doctor
just kind of says can we just live in
the present
of what we have that feels like it
captures something that a lot of
um not even just doctor like a lot of
shows or movies
either don't try to capture or capture
poorly which is that that sense from
somebody that
I love what we have
and I'm not able either right now or
possibly at all to have it be more than
this but I treasure this so much
can't we just hold on to this and as you
know as the other person has indicated I
would like this to be more but for the
doctors like I I can't and I just I just
want to keep having this
and it's a very real sense of melancholy
that can happen
because once you know the other person
once more it has the tendency to
diminish what it is you have now because
you know they're not completely happy
with it and she's just trying to hold on
to what it is they do have and again I
think that's well captured in the
performance I don't have too much else
to say uh there's the giant seam monster
which I don't get why they didn't call
it the Marka like they should have
I don't think it gets called something
else at some point it should have just
been the marker
I it just should have been that would
have been fun you know for for fans who
know what the heck that is
um but it's not for some reason actually
you know what the um the actor who plays
the I can't remember the character's
name but the the Sun the one who
initially is out for revenge against
Madame Chang and sort of joins along
with them turns out to be an ancestor of
one of the crew of jihunship that guy
he's actually he's got a really nice
presence he's got kind of a nice
Charisma he's very endearing I kind of
like him
I wish there was more of him like if
this had been the length of a proper
special you know closer to an hour I
think you know another five minutes
development on him he could have been
great as it is he's just
leaves a better impression than he
probably has any right to considering
how not particularly fleshed out the
character is I think the actor just
brings a good presence for him so I like
that Dan continues to be just kind of
cute and endearing and overall
I still have fun with this largely
on the back of loving pirate stuff I
just do
and I'm a sucker for it does that make
this good no no it's pretty disposable
uh ultimately and that's grading on the
curve of treating it like a standard
episode instead of a special uh viewing
it as a special like whoo
I
don't remember the last time I ranked
all the specials
oh I might have to do that soon
dang
dang well maybe after the tenant once or
should I do it before the tenant ones
like and and rank all the ones that have
had maybe as a lead-in I don't know I
gotta figure that out I haven't done
that in a while but I have a feeling
this is going to be down on the lower
end of those but
as a standard episode it's fun it's
something that that I don't feel the
need to skip
and that is a very lukewarm endorsement
I do understand that but
I don't hate it
legend of the sea Devils there's your
lukewarm endorsement I didn't hate it
but you know given how many people seem
to hate it
I think that's about as much phrases it
tends to get
what did you think about this one
Whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a patreon pays the bills
enables me to do this as my living even
if you can't help me out that way like
share subscribe you know the things
YouTube thinks they help but
um don't worry too much about it
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you were loved
you are the council and I am just
running the meetings and until next time
until
for the last time with Whitaker's doctor
this Council
is adjourned
[Music]
now my thanks my patreon supporters to
make this possible including Robin Moore
Zubin lipfula Tarak the thing that goes
Oink in the anime Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Linda Walters Jen t love
Auntie Kate 808 or Nabi likes the poodle
Robin Powell Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Adam RDL Taylor Dave Hall Shayla gourlay
and Rosalind Bennett
you can get uh my the bat I get all the
names right and then I can't talk if you
want to hear me stumble over my tongue
after saying your name it's in the
rewards here on the patreon
[Music]